en este vídeo vamos a pensar en lo que
sucede cuando multiplicamos o dividimos
entre 10 100 ó 1000
vamos a empezar con un ejemplo digamos
que queremos saber cuánto es 237 por 10
pausa el vídeo y trata de resolverlo muy
bien una forma de pensar en esto es que
esto es igual a 237 decenas así que si
pongo los valores de las posiciones aquí
esta es la posición de las unidades de
millar esta es la posición de las
centenas no lo escribo con palabras para
ahorrar espacio a veces no verás escrito
con las palabras unidades de millar
centenas esta es la posición de las
decenas y luego de las unidades bueno si
tuviera que decir sólo siete decenas
pondría el siete aquí y si tuviera que
decir treinta y siete decenas lo
escribiría así porque treinta decenas
son tres centenas y si tuviera que decir
237 decenas lo escribiría así porque
doscientos decenas es igual a dos
unidades de millar y entonces qué pasó
bueno todos mis dígitos se desplazaron
una posición
a la izquierda lo que solía estar en la
posición de las unidades ahora está en
la posición de las decenas lo que solía
estar en la posición de las decenas
ahora está en la posición de las antenas
y lo que solía estar en la posición de
las antenas ahora está en la posición de
las unidades de millar pero que hay en
la posición de las unidades tenemos que
poner algo en su lugar bueno ya no
tenemos ninguna unidad en este producto
así que simplemente pondremos un cero
entonces 237 por 10 es igual a 2.370
ahora una manera de pensar en esto es
que al multiplicar por 10 simplemente
puse un cero justo al final de este
número pero es importante darse cuenta
de lo que realmente sucedió y es que
cambie todos mis dígitos una posición a
la izquierda pero qué pasaría si
tuviéramos que ir en la otra dirección
qué pasaría si tenemos digamos 450 y
queremos dividirlo entre 10 bueno puedes
imaginarte que si multiplicar por 10
desplaza los dígitos una posición a la
izquierda entonces dividir entre 10
desplaza los dígitos 1
visión a la derecha y así tenemos un 4
en la posición de las antenas tenemos un
5 en la posición de las decenas y no
tenemos nada en la posición de las
unidades y así lo que solía estar en la
posición de las antenas ahora estará en
la posición de las decenas así que
pondré el 4 justo aquí y luego lo que
solía estar en la posición de las
decenas ahora estará en la posición de
las unidades de ese modo pondré este 5
aquí y no tendremos nada en la posición
de las unidades si tuviéramos algo aquí
y esto está un poco fuera del propósito
de este vídeo podrías comenzar a pensar
qué pasaría si no fuera un cero pero
tenemos que 450 divididos entre 10 es
sin duda igual a 45 ahora otra manera de
pensar en esto aparte del hecho de que
todos los dígitos se desplazaron una
posición a la derecha es que eliminamos
este cero que tenemos aquí cuando
dividimos entre 10 ahora ampliemos esto
digamos que tenemos 300 59 x 100 pausa
este vídeo y trata de encontrar el
resultado
bueno hay dos maneras en que puedes
pensar en ello podrías pensar en
términos de que aquí hay 359 centenas
así que pongamos algunos espacios aquí
digamos que esta es la posición de las
decenas de millar esta es la posición de
las unidades de millar esta es la
posición de las centenas esta de las
decenas y esta de las unidades
entonces si dijeras nueve centenas te
vas para acá si dijera 59 centenas sería
aquí porque 50 centenas son cinco
unidades de millar y si dijeras 359
centenas bueno trescientos centenas es
igual a tres decenas de millar y por
supuesto en este escenario no tendrías
decenas ni unidades lo que sucede es que
todos los dígitos se desplazaron dos
posiciones a la izquierda lo que estaba
en la posición de las unidades ahora
está en la posición de las centenas lo
que estaba en la posición de las decenas
ahora está en la posición de las
unidades de millar y lo que estaba en la
posición de las centenas ahora está en
la posición de las decenas de millar por
lo que este producto
a 35 1900 otra forma de pensar es que
esto es lo mismo que 359 por 10 por 10 y
ya sabemos que cada vez que multiplicas
por 10 9 sus dígitos una posición a la
izquierda así que si vas a multiplicar
por 10 dos veces vas a mover todos tus
dígitos
dos posiciones a la izquierda que es
exactamente lo que sucedió aquí entonces
con base en todo lo que hemos visto si
tengo 75 mil y quisiera dividirlo entre
100 cuál crees que va a ser el resultado
pausa el vídeo y trata de resolverlo por
tu cuenta muy bien ya hemos visto que si
divides entre 10 cambias los dígitos una
posición a la derecha y dividir entre
100 es realmente lo mismo que dividir
entre 10 2 veces así que solo
necesitamos cambiar todos nuestros
dígitos dos posiciones a la derecha
entonces lo que solía estar en la
posición de las decenas de millar ahora
va a estar en la posición de las
centenas lo que solía estar en la
posición de las unidades de millar ahora
va a estar en la posición de las decenas
y lo que solía estar en la posición de
las centenas ahora va a estar en la
posición de las unidades y lo que vamos
a obtener es que en lugar de siete
decenas de millar vamos a obtener siete
centenas en lugar de cinco unidades de
millar vamos a obtener cinco decenas y
en lugar de cero centenas ahora tenemos
cero unidades entonces esto es igual a
750 otra forma de pensar en esto y lo
hemos hablado antes es que si estás
dividiendo entre 100 y si tienes algunos
de estos ceros al final bueno entonces
eliminarías dos de estos ceros de la
derecha pero es muy importante saber por
qué sucedió eso ahora espero que hayas
visto un patrón así que te haré dos
preguntas más digamos que alguien camina
hacia ti en la calle y te dice oye
cuánto de 164 por mil y también te
pregunta cuánto es 198 mil dividido
entre 1000 pausa este vídeo y trata de
hacer eso muy bien probablemente ya has
visto el patrón así como multiplicar por
multiplicada por diez dos veces
multiplicar por mil se multiplica por
diez tres veces así que es igual a 164 x
10 x 10 por 10 lo que vamos a hacer es
desplazar todos los dígitos tres
posiciones a la izquierda de modo que en
lugar de 164 este 4 ya no está en la
posición de las unidades ahora está en
la posición de las unidades de millar y
eso tiene sentido si tomas cuatro
unidades y las multiplicas por 1000
obtendrás cuatro unidades de millar lo
que estaba en la posición de las decenas
ahora estará en la posición de las
decenas de millar y lo que estaba en la
posición de las centenas ahora va a
estar en la posición de las centenas de
millar y para representar este número
tendré que poner algo en la posición de
las centenas ahora no tengo centenas
tengo que poner algo en la posición de
las decenas ahora no tengo decenas y
tengo que poner algo en las unidades
el resultado será 164 mil y una vez más
eso es consistente con el patrón que
vimos hemos agregado tres ceros a la
derecha de este número de manera similar
qué va a pasar aquí bueno vamos a
cambiar todos los dígitos tres
posiciones a la derecha por lo que el 1
lo vamos a mover una dos tres posiciones
a la derecha así que lo que estaba en la
posición de las centenas de millar ahora
estará en la posición de las centenas lo
que estaba en la posición de las decenas
de millar lo vamos a mover una dos tres
posiciones a la derecha va a ir a la
posición de las decenas y lo que estaba
en la posición de las unidades de millar
va a cambiar uno dos tres dígitos a la
derecha estará en el lugar de las
unidades otra forma de pensar en esto es
que cuando dividimos entre mil
especialmente cuando tenemos estos tres
ceros al final van a desaparecer así que
en lugar de 100.000 aquí tenemos 100 en
lugar de 90.000 o 9 decenas de millar
esto va a ser nueve decenas y en lugar
de 8.000 esto será ocho por lo que es
igual a 198